who you intended benefits from
investments in infrastructure and basic
research are really important yes we're
really not making the the pace we should
and you know can a question really
whether this era of American
exceptionalism you know it is coming to
an end particularly as we see our lead
in technology perhaps a road nation
state competition is not zero-sum
competition that is the fact that the US
was so far had it that's not good for
the world if everybody could have had
our levels of science and health that
would be a fantastic thing you know it's
okay for China to invent cancer drugs
that cure patients in in the United
States so the fact that 5% of the
world's population were thirty percent
to the economic activity sixty percent
of the scientific R&D it wasn't natural
that that would continue to be the case
so we want them to catch up now we want
to as the leader keep setting a very
very high standard we don't want them to
catch up because we're slowing down or
even worse going into reverse
we should never want to hold anybody
else back then we should be trying to
build a future of shared success and
shared responsibility so what what I
think we need to do in America is to
stop majoring in the minors that is we
need this to look more at what other
countries are now doing better than we
are and instead of being a denial about
it learn from it well we have
laboratories of innovation all over the
world laboratories of the future all
over the world what are the Chinese
really good at answer a grenade in
capital and investing in technology and
infrastructure what are the Indians
really good at they're good at
technology and entrepreneurialism but
not good at aggregating capital is there
some way we can help each do the other
two Chinese what's their weakness they
tend to see a big engineering solution
for every problem in trying to run water
from the Yangtze River down to the
Yellow River they might draw them both
up we need to we need to be working on
these things together